costume trois pièces moustache
impeccable et démarches savamment étudié
cette élégance à l'ancienne c'est la clé
du succès de guillaume ii bernadac à
shanghai
sow aurier today ya bien que son métier
professeur de savoir vivre à la
française
cela fait cinq ans qu'ils enseignent aux
chinois et ce dès le plus jeune âge sauf
qu'à newman me audio cette donne please
ces enfants sont âgés de 4 à 12 ans mais
il n'est apparemment jamais trop tôt
pour apprendre à bien se tenir quitte à
souffrir un peu
tant qu'ils se tiennent bien droit ça ne
va pas le faire mal et de vous rien
sentir mais s'il commence à
s'avachir là ils vont sentir une petite
tension donc c'est un bon exercice pour
garder ses épaules en arrière
la leçon du jour comment boire le thé
avec classe pas si facile quand on est
encore qu'une toute petite fille espère
que tu
effectues rêver d'une lettre qu'il a
reçue resservir
simply red
et
rigueur
ok la culture chinoise donc on boit
beaucoup de thé notamment à ces jeunes
donc ils ont une manière qui différente
de la nôtre faty l'ont dit ils ont des
tailles différentes qui n'ont pas deux
ans notamment et ce seront des toute
petite tu as vraiment tout petit donc
c'est juste des gorges est donc ce n'est
pas on ne garde pas autant de liquide
est dans l'impasse tu crois que tout ça
te servira un jour
oui quand j'aurai un dîner où il nous
fait ça servirait à montrer mon élégance
et ma bonne éducation
car pour les chinois la france reste le
symbole absolu du raffinement et du
style ses parents n'auraient d'ailleurs
pas imaginer un professeur d'une autre
nationalité
je pense que les bonnes manières ont été
inventés par la noblesse française
et donc pour apprendre à ma fille à bien
se tenir je me suis dit qu'il fallait
absolument un professeur français
dans huit jours ses enfants passeront
même un examen mais l'excellence à la
française à un prix plus de 1000 euros
pour 2 heures de cours par semaine
pendant deux mois à rien n'est trop beau
pour cette nouvelle génération de
chinois dans cette ville qui s'ouvre au
monde
à 10 heures d'avion de paris sur la côte
est de la chine
shanghai
en trente ans le gouvernement a fait de
cette modeste cité portuaire
la vitrine de la réussite chinoise le
nouveau centre économique de l' empire
du milieu
avec ses 18 millions d'habitants la
ville la plus peuplée du pays débordent
d'énergie de jour comme de nuit
à tel point que certains la surnomment
déjà la nouvelle new york
symbole de cette ambition sans limites
les gratte ciel qui peuplent l'horizon
grâce à une croissance annuelle de près
de 10% la mégalopole en compte déjà cinq
mille et 120 nouvelles tours sortent de
terre chaque année
pour beaucoup de chinois la réussite est
synonyme de mode de vie à l'occidentale
du coup à shanghai de nombreux français
tirent leur épingle du jeu
à laisser partir libre ils sont près de
20 mille à avoir élu domicile dans cette
ville où rien ne semble impossible
[Musique]
le meilleur
thomas vous vivre ici depuis dix ans il
est toujours fasciné par cette métropole
partagé en deux
d'un côté de la rivière huangpu
il y à shanghai l'ultra moderne
ici on a tout le quartier financier
généralement c'est une banque une tour
c'est une question
d'orgueil moi je pense que c'est
vraiment de l'orgueil voulu afficher
pour mettre shanghai est vraiment sur
une des villes les plus puissantes au
moins
mais de l'autre côté la cité historique
se révèle
là moi c'est pour moi c'est mon quartier
préféré de shanghai j'ai toujours rêvé
d'habiter ce quartier là c'est pour moi
là toute la beauté la gloire de shanghai
c'est frénétique c'est c'est beau c'est
tout l'héritage colonial
thomas a quitté paris en 2006 pour venir
ouvrir ici dans le quartier historique
l'un des tout premiers cabinets
d'architecturé d'intérieur de chine
donc j'ai vu ton tapis
c'est pas mal ça tu en sois c'était
vraiment le parfait timing pour venir
s'installer là il y avait vraiment une
ouverture une demande de la chine de
faire venir des des entrepreneurs
étrangers le marché design n'existait
pas du tout à l'époque il y avait aucun
marché n'y a pas de structure
aujourd'hui l'agencé l'une des plus
réputées de shanghai est une trentaine
de collaborateurs chinois et français
travaillent pour thomas sa signature un
style graphique contemporain très loin
des intérieurs traditionnelle asiatique
bonjour
[Musique]
ce matin l'architecte a rendez vous avec
anna une jeune styliste elle l'a
justement engagé pour qu'ils lui aménage
un intérieur ultra moderne dans cette
tour du quartier d'affaires le plus cher
de la ville
sault tous deux
se fige démolition par sow à just wrong
to check with you to der schritt
ordinaire le chantier situé au 56e étage
est colossal
1200 mètres carrés sur trois niveaux
ce triplex appartenaient jusqu'ici au
beau père d'anne à un riche industriel
il en a fait cadeau au couple pour son
mariage un cadeau à près de 20 millions
d'euros
ça désespère guirlandes s'agit si oui si
wayne hemingway pour la décoration la
jeune femme a souhaité que le luxe
s'invite dans toutes les pièces jusque
dans le moindre détail
sur les routes la glisse
au canada doivent se dérouler tout
chèque plusieurs band swing poule
sourire idiot et ceux pour qui ils
auront fini il reste à modifier la forme
de la piscine intérieure encore six mois
de patience pour ana avant de pouvoir y
plonger mais elle est déjà conquise
[Musique]
thomas aime les combinaisons couleurs
c'est très chic et ça correspond à mon
goût
les chinois ont tendance à utiliser
beaucoup de boire tout est en bois
ça n'est pas très chaleureux
c'est un style qui correspond plus aux
personnes âgées
pour thomas c'est un contrat à 250000
euros pourtant avant de pouvoir débuter
les aménagements intérieurs
l'architecte doit encore obtenir le feu
vert d'un visiteur particulier
le maître feng-shui
son rôle étudier les énergies d'un lieu
afin d'apporter l'harmonie à ses
habitants
aujourd'hui encore cet art millénaire
est pris très au sérieux par les chinois
un avis négatif sur le chantier et c'est
tout le travail de thomas qui peut être
remise en cause alors vaut mieux
travailler plus en amont parce que sinon
bah il ya beaucoup de choses qui vont
être perturbés changer etc il va prend
du retard et on va se faire taper dessus
à l'aide de sa boussole le maître
feng-shui analyse soigneusement
l'orientation de chaque pièce
faire face à la rivière c'est beau pour
le feng shui parce que nous sommes
entrés depuis 2004 dans une période de
chance qui va s'étend jusqu'en 2024
ces deux décennies si on voit la rivière
à l'ouest on aura beaucoup de chance
surtout avec l'argent
la chose qui m'inquiétait c'était la
pièce qu'il ya sous la piscine parce
qu'il ne faut pas que les gens dorment
où vivent sous l'eau
mais il n'y a rien et donc je suis
rassuré
heureusement pour thomas ses plans
semblent permettre la bonne circulation
des énergies
ma conclusion c'est que cet endroit va
être très chanceux
c'est vraiment une bonne chose pour moi
au rythme effréné où la mégalopole se
développe le business de thomas n'est
pas prêt de s'essouffler
mais cette mutation ne fait pas
forcément les affaires de ceux qui à
shanghai au contraire sont en quête
d'authenticité
dans les rues encombrées ok faut juste
faire attention aux voitures qui vont
tourner allez c'est parti on y voit un
cortège de bicyclettes tente de se
frayer un chemin au milieu des voitures
et des scooters
tout le monde est bon à la tête du
groupe fabrice 29 ans ce guide français
propose à ses clients une immersion à
vélo au coeur du shanghai populaire qui
a déjà bien changé
y a pas de fumée parce que toutes les
petites pétrole sont fortes et les
criques je croyais que c'était très très
peu lyon avec gars ils polluent et
pour offrir un aperçu de la bi
traditionnelle à marcq un touriste et à
gabriel et joy deux expatriés
fraîchement débarqué le guide n'hésite
pas à pousser les portes des maisons
dont celle ci ce sont six familles qui
cohabitent donc la cuisine et bien sûr
partagé oui est différente à chacun sa
table chacun son frigo donc ceux qui
vivent ici sont plutôt des personnes
relativement âgées les jeunes eux
préfèrent vivre dans une grosse tour
tout neuf avec le courant que le
chauffage d'isolation etc voici un
disque parce qu'encore une fois bon il
est pas très tôt je pense que j'entends
pas mais bon c'est quand même un peu un
très vif et personnes nous invitent
leurs noms à rentrer leurs aujourd'hui
grâce à son mandarin impeccable fabrice
arrivée en chine comme étudiant il y a
neuf ans n'a aucun mal à se faire
accepter si jagr
jumbo je vois là
je sors nous ont pas du tout
donc la voilà la petite terrasse sympa
qui aujourd'hui sert surtout à prendre
le linge les personnes âgées ans gilles
sont assez ouverts qui est assez
contente est assez fier de ce qu'elles
sont et de ce qu'elles font donc oui ils
sont ils sont ouverts aux partages et
essayer du coup assez sympathique c'est
des gens assez sympathique encore une
fois en parlant chinois et avec un grand
sourire ça vaut quand même beaucoup de
portes en chine incroyable on a
l'impression que c'était deux sont des
petites maisons qui vont être super
nickel à l'intérieur les gens qui y
vivent presque rien comme comme des cinq
cantons très étonné voire allez c'est
parti
attention au petit recul atteint
mais fabrice ne pourra peut-être plus
faire visiter le vieux shanghai très
longtemps en voyant voit encore les
maisons en bois là avec son groupe il
s'enfonce dans l'un des derniers
lilongue de la ville un dédale de
ruelles où vivent les familles les plus
pauvres
depuis une quinzaine d'années ces
quartiers sont en voie de disparition
donc là on est on est dans un quartier
qui est qui était relativement
traditionnels comme en témoigne ce côté
gauche de la rue et le côté droit qui
était pareil il ya encore deux ans a été
rasée pour faire
une résidence plutôt chic donc et ici on
est vraiment frontière entre les deux
mondes souvent incapables de payer un
loyer dont ces immeubles modernes les
anciens habitants sont relogés par les
autorités
mais comme cet homme ils sont rarement
satisfait de ce déménagement
juste en face mais mon ancien
appartement a été démoli
si je suis content
non mais je dois attendre leurs
logements collectifs
pour l'instant j'essaie de supporter la
vie dans cette maison vieille de 220 ans
vous vous rendez compte
ce qui semble immuable en revanche ce
sont les habitudes culinaires les
clients de fabrice vont découvrir le
petit déjeuner traditionnel satire
procureur voici votre comores dont on
tient à cette gêne vous voulez des
petits raviolis
je tiens
goodyear
typiquement shanghai
ça ce sont des petits pains en avait
c'est pas mal donc ça se prend pas ça se
mange comme ça ça c'est un genre de
petites pizzas des saveurs auquel les
pas les français ne sont pas vraiment
habitué à ses côtés qui est surprenant
[Musique]
et choix mange très peu secret
voila voila je la fais tomber dans la
fondue ça va pas du tout événement
relaté un gage la bombe et c'est un
gâchis tu repars à vélo et vous verrez
c'est un petit bout de nos complexes
c'est très bon mais le petit lutin belge
suis pas sûr
des échoppes de rues jusqu'aux adresse
chic shanghai compte plus de 45000
restaurant c'est trois fois plus qu'à
paris et depuis quelques années la ville
attire de grands chefs étrangers qui
tentent de mixer leur art avec les
saveurs exotiques
au petit matin à la périphérie de la
ville
le marché aux poissons s'éveille c'est
dans ce lieu haut en couleurs que les
restaurateurs viennent s'approvisionner
en produits de la mer
[Musique]
michael il vient toutes les semaines
accompagné de son bras droit chinois
robin ça c'est très bon c'est du crabe
du crabes de rivière
dans son alsace natale ce jeune
cuisinier était simple chefs de partis
en chine en moins d'un an il s'est
retrouvé à la tête de sa première
cuisine
pourtant après quatre années passées
dans le pays michael est loin d'avoir
fini son apprentissage des spécialités
locales
[Musique]
oui mais si tu leur donnes de la
nourriture elles vont bouger
ces tortues crocodiles d'apparemment
j'utilise savander
des restaurants chinois dans la soupe
c'est très bon et on les aime aussi à la
vapeur des spécimens inconnu en france
comme c'est étrange palourde royale
comment aux cuisines ça on peut les
manger crus ou les faire frire
5 2
il les mange cru juste avec de la sauce
soja
sashimi c'est bizarre c'est non
au but c'est assez doux mais en bouche
c'est très élastique
c'est vraiment éprouvé que nous on
cuisine pas quoi dire à nice
voulait vendre et à qui
ça c'est apprendre je tombe sur un truc
comme ça c'est 18 qui sont déjà ouvertes
et en faite le
robin me disais qu il ait vent donc sa
tasse en pièce pour 20 a émis ce qui
équivaut à 3 euros
c'est marché français
ouais un peu quand même il manque il
manque les étalages et puis là et puis
le petit poissonnier qui crie il est
beau mon poisson qui te montrent le
poisson devant levante yeux c'est pas
c'est pas vraiment la même histoire ici
ce matin c'est du homard que michael
veut prendre dans ses filets voilà un
peu fatigué ça un client lui a demandé
de concocter un menu unique pour un
dîner à domicile un bon
on va quand même chez un client qui est
assez exigeant à très exigeant même on
va faire une
jolie
avec
ses dans son restaurant des beaux
quartiers que michael va créer son menu
du soir sont plats phares les fameux
raviolis omar a priori rien de compliqué
pour le chef et son équipe
mais pour séduire les chinois le
français a vite compris qu'il devait
adapter ses recettes
ils ont besoin d'avoir énormément de
d'intensité dans tout ce qu'ils mangent
ils recherchent vraiment le comment dire
les pistes beaucoup gonds tennis des
crises
répétées aux pans de la verrie s'attaque
pour sa commande du soir le chef dont
une association inédite son homard va
prendre des accents asiatiques
donc on va récupérer les ingrédients
qu'on a chez nous
les légumes le homard et on va rajouter
on va rajouter une herbe asiatiques
comme le coran on va mettre du basilic
on va se donner ça avec la sauce soja
voilà c'était surprend et puis essayer
de leur faire plaisir en en montrant
qu'on arrive à allier leurs cuisines les
plus la répu la nôtre
c'est ravioli donneront le ton à tout le
repas un subtil équilibre entre saveur
chinoise et influences occidentales
mais rien ne garantit aux français que
ses convives seront conquis
à shanghai de plus en plus de clients
ont les moyens de faire appel à des
chefs à domicile comme michael car la
ville est désormais la plus fortunée de
chine elle compte 160 mille millionnaire
et pour eux rien n'est trop beau
crystal est la fille d'un riche banquier
sa passion la mode
[Musique]
je veux vraiment que tu porte cette
tenue là tu vois après en avoir essayé
quelques unes tu as trouvé la bonne
c'est vrai qu'elle est super confortable
la jeune femme et ses amis ont leurs
habitudes chez cette créatrice
shanghaienne ces dernières années la
ville s'est imposée comme la capitale
asiatique de la haute couture
la coupe est très pure avec des petits
détails brillant et dans le dos c'est
transparent donc c'est un peu sexy mais
pas trop je crois que les filles
chinoises ne veulent pas trop se montrer
ni être trop sexy je suis un peu serré
au niveau du buste elle me plaît
beaucoup avec très élégante parfaite
et il ya 700 ici j'aime beaucoup oui un
peu comme angelina jolie chacune de ces
robes coûte en moyenne 1500 euros et les
chinoises sont de plus en plus
nombreuses à pouvoir se les offrir
il faut dire que ces dix dernières
années le salaire moyen a été multiplié
par 3 dans le pays il atteint
aujourd'hui près de 600 euros par mois
comme la classe moyenne s'enrichit les
gens les moyens d'une vie meilleure
oui ils ont plus d'argent
et ils sont prêts à payer plus pour de
la bonne nourriture une bonne qualité de
vie ils font attention à la manière du
thil s'habille
il regarde les séries américaines
les films hollywoodiens et ils veulent
faire partie de ce monde ils veulent
vivre une vie de rêve
cristal elle aussi doit choisir sa tenue
car elle organise dans quelques jours un
événement déterminant pour sa carrière
je crois que je vais porter celle là
pour accueillir les invités parce qu
elle est élégante
mais pas trop brillante
je ris que tous mes invités brille plus
que moi quand il arrive
à 26 ans elle fait partie d'une nouvelle
génération d'entrepreneurs chinois
tourner vers internet
au deuxième étage de ce bâtiment
plusieurs dizaines d'entre eux partagent
cet espace de travail
décoration branché ambiance détendue on
se croirait dans la silicon valley
c'est ici que la jeune chef d'entreprise
et sa petite équipe mettent la touche
finale à leur start up
[Musique]
maintenant tu cliques sur télécharger
la caisse qui apparaissent
çà c'est aaron c'est notre responsable
opérationnel
il s'occupe de plein de choses surtout
des relations médias
et voilà maggie notre informaticienne
le concept cristal la puiser dans sa
passion pour les vêtements la location
de tenues haut de gamme entre
particuliers
aujourd'hui les événements mondains
n'arrête pas de se multiplier en chine
mais personne ne veut porter les mêmes
vêtements à chaque fois parce que les
photos sont postés sur les réseaux
sociaux et il ne faut pas qu'on vous
voit deux fois dans la même tenue c'est
pour ça que nous avons créé une
application vous n'avez plus besoin de
dépenser tout votre argent en nouvelles
tenues vous pouvez juste les louer le
lancement officiel de l'application a
lieu dans trois jours pour l'occasion
crystal organise une grande fête à
laquelle elle veut convier les
personnalités les plus influentes du
monde de la mode on ne dépasse pas 150
invités cette nouvelle génération fier
et ambitieuse veut aujourd'hui être
reconnu comme l'égal de l'occident
et pour cela les chinois sont prêts à
adopter certains usages venus d'ailleurs
comme les cours de savoir-vivre de
guillaume il y a cinq ans il était
étudiant en commerce ici à l'université
tombe j l'une des plus grandes du pays
c'est en discutant avec ses camarades
chinois que l'idée lui est venue les
jeunes les adolescents posé beaucoup de
questions sur à l'avenir si j'allais 6 à
l'étudiant france comment est-ce qu'on
se faisait à bize comment on allait
manger à table comment on se faisait des
amis guillaume décident d'exploiter
cette curiosité pour les habitudes
françaises et pour parfaire sa formation
il n'a pas besoin d'aller chercher bien
loin il peut compter sur son héritage
familial
la petite histoire c'était que c'était
mon arrière grand père et mon art un
canton khl qui avait été
instituteur et les tuteurs à la cour du
maroc dans les années dans les années 20
il en citant les mathématiques le
français que des souvenirs va se
comporter être poli voilà par la suite
ma grand mère y est né donc il a passé
ses premières années et c'est grâce à
elle c'est par elle que que j'ai reçu
cette passion pour le pour le savoir
vivre à la française une passion qu'il
transmet aujourd'hui aux adultes chinois
soucieux d'améliorer leurs connaissances
des manières occidentales
de fox avatar
en france talent
dans ce club très sélect de shanghai
guillaume ii bernadac dispense un cours
particulièrement prisés les arts de la
table
enfin sur ie9
le plus grand armé de son
impressionnante collection de couverts
monsieur le professeur peut débuter les
travaux pratiques
que soit
le fond d'âge junior les fruits non au
oui
les huîtres en
moto barre de soual celle là c'est pour
les raviolis
ishow leucate est je tiens c'est donc au
pour la sauce yes we nous n'avons pas
tous amis une paire de baguettes une
cuillère et c'est tout c'est simple
cette journée de cours est facturé 850
euros par personne et malgré ce tarif le
succès du français ne se dément pas car
guillaume répond exactement aux attentes
de la clientèle chinoise
ces gens là ont une image à ses preneurs
onirique même de notre culture donc
elles veulent aussi un peu rêver donc on
le sait en plus que leur offre d'avoir
un peu accès le temps d'une journée à
quelques moments peu sophistiqué où
elles vont vivre un peu le luxe à la
française
tway icahn style it
c'est possible
battus que not what you cannot au podium
les clientes de guillaume son chef
d'entreprise banquière ou femme au foyer
contrairement à leurs aînés elles ont la
possibilité de voyager à l'étranger et
pour s'intégrer non non
moving une fente hockey elles sont
prêtes à faire des efforts
comment vous mangeriez à la chinoise
juste décontracté
champel okoumi volontiers
mais les français de shanghai eux aussi
sont souvent curieux de mieux connaître
la culture chinoise
ce dimanche matin thomas l'architecte a
réservé une surprise à son fils
il ya six ans est né ici et ses loisirs
sont ceux d'un vrai petit chinois
s'est jamais vu direction le marché aux
grilles on regarde ça
[Musique]
ça fera
salut la regarde passer les criques et
chinois sa taille généralement les gens
ils mettraient dans
leurs fenêtres ou devant leur maison et
a fait un compagnon
c'est très impressionnant être vraiment
très gros et la tavelure garde
[Musique]
d'accord
l'élevage de ces insectes notamment pour
les combats est un sport national
des dizaines d'éleveurs sont regroupés
sous cet ovale où il propose fièrement
leurs plus beaux spécimens
certains coûtent plus de 100 euros
on est loin du jardin d'acclimatation
c'est évident mais mettez extrêmement
ludique c'est fabuleux ça rapport à la
nature dans cette jungle urbaine pas les
choses comme ça
thomas ne parle pas vraiment mandarin
alors quand il faut poser des questions
c'est son fils qui prend le relais
[Musique]
sa seconde mais bien sûr
ça t'es un gros
oui un gogo il chante parent demande
comment ça coûte de bobo
le prix tu veux acheter un gros bof ça
dépend mon petit il y en a à 10 à 20 ou
à 38 ans c'est ce qui chante le mieux
qui coûte le plus cher
elia est inscrit à l'école franco
chinoises depuis ses deux ans une
évidence pour son père c'est un devoir
et c'est un effort intellectuel en
réserves en sang
forcément sa timide et vêtements mais au
moins tu as intégré en train de
comprendre et de comprendre qu'ils sont
la structure et je trouve que pour un
enfant qui est important c'est important
qu'ils luttent à comprendre est en
contact avec elle le développement
économique de shanghai a aussi
profondément modifié la famille chinoise
faire on va se promener et cela a donné
naissance à des pratiques étonnantes
dans ce parc du centre de la ville à
deux pas des habitants venus flâner au
bord de l'eau se déroule chaque dimanche
un drôle de manège des centaines de
parapluies sont déployés le long des
allées sur chacun d'eux une petite
annonce la la c'est une femme qui
cherche un homme donc la femme elle
mesure 1 m 64 elle est née en juin 1984
et est à tout indescriptible sur ce
cas-là ce qu'elle gagne et un descriptif
sur le type d'homme recherché rock folk
qui façonneraient sa taille là il faut
que crayon tel et tel métier
nous sommes au beau milieu d'un club de
rencontres à ciel ouvert sauf qu'ici ce
sont les parents qui viennent chercher
l'âme soeur pour leurs enfants
pour cela il n'hésite pas à exhiber les
plus belles photos de leur progéniture
les caméras ne sont pas vraiment les
bienvenus être célibataire après 25 ans
en chine c'est un déshonneur pour toute
la famille
pourtant à shanghai comme dans les
autres grandes villes du pays les jeunes
sont de moins en moins pressé de se
marier dans les années 70-80 ses enfants
qui étaient mariées très jeunes qui
avaient une vie déjà d absolument de
prêts destinés
décidée par les parents et c'est vrai
que cette nouvelle génération ne
respecte aucun code en fait donc donc
aujourd'hui son plumard ya vingt ans je
ne serai plus tard rue c'est une façon
de s'affirmer face aux parents les parcs
c'est le lieu où toutes les générations
chinoise et se rencontrent une étape
incontournable pour découvrir le vrai
visage de shanghai
voyez un concert de jazz mais il n'y a
pas beaucoup de public la visite que
fabrice propose se termine à cushing
l'un des jardins publics les plus
fréquentés de la ville
ici tous les matins des centaines de
retraités viennent entretenir leur forme
riche en couleurs oui on vient tous les
jours qu'ils fassent 40° qu'il neige
malgré leurs 80 printemps ces anciens
ouvriers en bâtiment manille le diabolo
à la perfection
un sport plus acrobatiques qu'il n'y
paraît
[Musique]
gabriel tu m'as l'air un peu intrépide
ah oui moi je voulais essayer richard
attends attends
c'est un pas que j'ai eu l'occasion
d'essayer c'est pas très concluant pour
l'instant mais bon moment
pour les moins habiles heureusement il
reste le jogging du matin en version
chinoise
quelques pas de danse héritées du
communisme
ces gens là ont grandi avec la
révolution culturelle et les bonnes
habitudes inculquée par mao et celle ci
en fait partie c'est à dire que le matin
on fait des exercices on se lève et on
embrasse la vie
joy la française n'a plus qu'à suivre le
rythme
certains
vous aviez déjà penser comme ça on est
pas
[Musique]
regarder on va aller ensemble à paris
problème à paris film et la star fils
bela store
pour les élèves en culottes courtes de
guillaume c'est le grand jour
le fan aux cérémonies
nation
et week end quatre programmes les
parents ont tous fait le déplacement
pour assister à l'examen de fin d'année
un examen couronné par une épreuve
périlleuse se déplacer avec grâce la
culotte
[Musique]
ce programme aura coûté plus de 1000
euros à ce prix là malgré quelques faux
pas tout le monde gagne à la fin les
iphones
des diplômes qui font la fierté des
parents car tout ce rêve d'envoyer leurs
enfants étudier à l'étranger
[Musique]
son grand frère fait déjà ses études aux
états unis je me suis aperçu qu'il avait
beaucoup évolué en termes de caractère
de morale et de connaissances depuis
qu'il est là bas quant à ma fille elle
souhaite devenir créatrice de mode je
l'enverrai aussi à l'étranger
ces cours depuis serviront ils
l'aideront à s'intégrer dans la société
locale à se faire des amis et bien
d'autres choses
les bougies juan frigo le chao sur un
frigo on espère leur donner plus de code
plus de clés pour pouvoir peut-être
s'intégrer facilement dans nos sociétés
plus facilement
c'est moi réussir chez nous aussi je
pense que j'ai encore beaucoup de
travail ici en chine là encore beaucoup
à faire
des perspectives professionnelles qui
vont retenir guillaume ici pour
plusieurs années avec ses business
potentiel shanghai la trépidante attire
toujours plus de français il y à 25 ans
ils étaient cent aujourd'hui ils sont
près de 20000
dans cette résidence luxueuse au 60e
étage
michael le gastronome s'apprête à
défendre les couleurs de la france
dans une heure il va servir le dîner
d'exception commandé par son client
nie tout en bloc
un oui le foot déchaîne sol sont amuse
bouche des huîtres recouverte d'un
granit et au pamplemousse
mais la chaleur de la ville pourrait
avoir raison de son entrée glace et
je suis en train de
remettre le granité au froid parce que
le temps qu'on arrive il a pris un
forcément vu qui fait 35 degrés dehors
il a fondu pas si facile de travailler
en territoire inconnu
c'est différent parce qu'on n'est pas en
cuisine pas avec notre matériel on
cuisine pas avec nos avec les moyens
qu'on a dans un geste en a forcément on
a quand même une pression parce que
comme une image à garder l'homme qui
reçoit ce soir ses marques jouent riche
héritier d'une fortune immobilière
comment
lui est déjà conquis par la cuisine
franco chinoise de michael il a dépensé
plus de 3000 euros pour la faire
découvrir à ses convives du soir
avec mike j'attends toujours des
surprises tout ce qu'il fait est
fantastique
finalement la réputation du chef est
intacte les huîtres auront bien leur
touche de fraîcheur tout est bien qui
finit bien
les granités bien pris
[Musique]
je trouve ça wow
[Rires]
j'ai déjà souvent manger des huîtres
mais là le goût est très différente
[Musique]
assaisonner automates avec la
citronnelle à laisser partir les fameux
raviolis au homard à leur tour vont
faire leur petit effet
[Musique]
c'est une très belle combinaison de
nourriture occidentales et chinoises it
et les épices sont très adaptés à la
saison c'est très rafraîchissant
c'est excellent
bravo pour ton repas
c'était incroyable
michael a tenu son rôle d'ambassadeur de
la gastronomie française ce soir encore
la nuit c'est une autre shanghai qui
s'éveille
encore plus effervescente
[Musique]
ici les magasins ferment rarement avant
minuit les habitants vivent leur vie
comme si de rien n'était à la lumière
des néons
[Musique]
crystal elle s'apprête à être sous les
feux des projecteurs
petit détour par chez elle avant sa
grande soirée d'inauguration
donc voilà le salon c'est là où l'on
déjeune où l'on dîne
est ici en gros c'est mon salon qui sert
aussi de dressing et parfois je joue du
piano
elle partage avec un ami cet appartement
de 100 mètres carrés
presque trop petit pour cette reine du
shopping
voilà mon placard yam et au
mes pantalons mais jean
ici ce sont mes mentaux et mes petits
sacs et ici mes autres sacs
mais ce n'est qu'une petite partie
contrairement à la génération de ses
parents
crystal à des idoles bien plus
occidental et luxueuse que mao et le
communisme
j'aime beaucoup chanel donc j'en achète
beaucoup je pense que c'est parce que
j'ai lu beaucoup de livres sur coco
chanel
j'admire la femme et la chef
d'entreprise
pour moi c'est une belle personne
j'aimerais lui ressembler
pour la jeune entrepreneuse des mois
d'efforts s'apprête à se concrétiser ce
soir
personnalités de la mode des médias
crystal a convié tous ceux qui comptent
à shanghai pour le lancement de son
application dédiée aux vêtements de luxe
aujourd'hui est un jour très spécial
pour moi après deux ans de travail one
more closet rencontre enfin son public
preuve que le secteur de la mode a de
l'avenir ici ces deux investisseurs un
chinois et un américain ont déjà injecté
1 million de dollars dans son projet
[Applaudissements]
shanghai est en train de devenir une
sorte de capitale pour les startups
chinoise c'est pour ça que l'entreprise
de cristal est basé ici l'idée calcul
d'abord le marché chinois avant de
s'exporter
la chine veut que le monde entier
entendent parler d'elle ce n'est que le
début mais j'ai confiance
je sais qu un avenir radieux s'ouvre à
nous
kristen n'a pas peur d'afficher ses
objectifs conquérir 10 mille
utilisateurs dès le premier mois et cinq
millions d'ici trois ans des ambitions
sans limites ou presque à l'image de la
mégalopole chinoise